cucumbers harvested from the young
family farm these fresh vegetables need
to be handled with care
they spoil fast that's why farmer
Aminata
has to ensure they get to the market
today they're carefully packed in crates
and put in her car we just finished
harvesting will transport them in the
evening when it's not so hot the Aminata
family owns these four hectares of land
each family member has his own specialty
from livestock fruit to vegetable
farming the brothers oversee its
management while Aminata has to ensure
the produce gets to its final
destination if I take care of it it's
better and more efficient than when I
leave it to my brothers they don't
understand the market very well they
just want to unload the goods
for them it's more about the money but
I'm much more patient she's now on her
way to the first destination Aminata
who's a certified translator initially
didn't want to venture into agribusiness
she studied in South Africa and got a
diploma finally she arrives in this
small market stall located in the centre
of Bamako one of her customers forgot to
place an order by telephone she's
disappointed after getting less
cucumbers than she had expected that is
for another customer please leave it I
cannot give it to you everything must be
weighed carefully otherwise you'll be
ripped off says Aminata they know each
other very well
I have a different weighing scale than
hers
you see hers is quite small and there is
a technique among the vendors where they
interfere with the weighing scale so
they get more and we lose especially
with her we always argue despite the
hard negotiations I mean Atta still
maintains her customers she's very good
at her job and must ensure she gets good
prices for her produce therefore her
company has updated production methods
the entire year she's now able to
harvest cucumbers thanks to the modern
technology founder net house the power
house has a microclimate you could say
it's a mosquito net for the plants it
protects them not only against insects
but also against rain and the weather
the brain behind this farming is a me
Natas father he worked at the UN as an
agricultural expert for 30 years his
children followed suit iya I'm very
proud of my family I'd never choose
another they have talent and stick
together a foodie patient and assertive
at the same time I mean not and her
family plan to expand their business in
order to meet BOM echoes growing demand
for fresh vegetables